so
so
[Music]
[Music]
this
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
do
hello hey matt hey john luke
how's it going hello everybody um it's
going
good dude i'm excited to watch you play
some playstation while i ask
uh ask the wonderful people to ask me
some questions
um yeah hey so for those who
are tuning in but don't know one happy
playstation 5 launch day hopefully
uh all of you who had ordered one do get
one i've been seeing a lot of chatter
about uh different companies getting
delaying them and stuff like that so if
you are all waiting this morning
uh godspeed and hopefully we can help
pass the time while you wait for
the ups or fedex or whoever is trying to
arrive at your door
uh with a playstation 5. um but yeah i'm
john luke video producer this is matt
padgett he
is the one who reviewed the playstation
5. so if you have any hot questions
uh i think both of us will be able to
answer
those um so let's get right into it matt
yeah so how's everyone doing we're
looking at the youtube and the twitch
chat
uh but we're gonna we're gonna jump
right into a game yeah john luke
why don't you uh why don't you throw us
into the first game on our docket
yeah absolutely so we got i got a lot of
games on here so where i'm happy to jump
into anything that anyone wants to know
uh but we're gonna start with call of
duty cold war because uh the embargo for
that actually lifted this morning so we
can show it
uh for the first time so figure why not
we just uh
hop into hopping on this one for a hot
minute
i don't know if i'll be able to do
multiplayer the
servers i don't know if they're up or if
people are even playing
um but at the very least we can show the
campaign
um because i i actually quite
uh enjoyed the uh campaign
and there's a lot of cool things
specifically with the playstation 5
version
which we'll talk about the the dual
sense
is it your typical call of duty campaign
it is your typical call of duty campaign
it's your
typical black ops campaign um they
actually took some
some influence from uh black ops 2 where
it has like side missions and like
multiple endings right
um that was cool because i that's the
only call of duty
um that really ever did that and i
always thought that was kind of weird
that
they didn't didn't really show that
after why is it making me do all this
again
i'm not sure uh but hey got some
questions
uh ps4 controllers do work on the ps5
angry ford super [ __ ]
um you can only use them on ps4 games
though unfortunately
um you connect them just like you would
on the ps4 uh
and then when you launch a ps5 game with
a dualshock 4
or another ps4 controller it says hey
connect to dual sense all right we're
going to show you
my favorite level case pb we will get to
demon souls
very excited to show that off confirms
and uh john t
no quick resume uh but load times are
very quick
um so it's
uh jean-luc
psyche cia that's funny oh yeah you
gotta put in your own name
that's funny uh so so yeah yeah so no
quick resume but
um even even though that is a really
cool feature it doesn't feel essential
uh because you are loading in and out of
these games quickly
yeah that's how i feel about it um like
i'm the next
sort of curious how much i'm actually
going to use quick resume on the xbox
get out
[ __ ] like i do think it's cool for sure
um
if i need to lower the game or raise
myself probably raise myself i'm
usually pretty quiet
yeah i agree um
the it is the bummer that you can't play
ps5 you the ps4
um specifically the games that
you don't need the dual sense for like
they're definitely like
you you could play actually any ps5 game
with a dual shock for and i bet you
could do fine
um but like astro would be a bummer to
not play with
the dual sense uh the dual sense is
awesome like the dual sense is like
absolutely my favorite controller uh
of this launch like i think it's it's
it's incredible
and i'm a huge xbox fan um
and i love the xbox one controller i
love the series x controller
but uh the dual sense is just uh
freaking incredible
uh and john luke is actually really
excited about the dual sense features
for call of duty
and uh he will explain to you why it is
such an awesome controller to use
uh yeah absolutely so what i
really really like about it is um they
basically
uh customize the adaptive triggers to
function differently for every gun
um so the
uh in the case of like the left the left
trigger obviously is down the site
and that has like a different different
pressure based on like if i'm using this
rifle versus i'm using this pistol so
it's a little bit less
the machine gun has like a very like you
have to really hold it down
to pull it like a like a heavy machine
gun and then they also have like
different pressures
for when you're um
shooting as well so like it's just
there's there's
it's it can be hard to explain without
having to use it yourself but there's
there's a level of feeling
when using the adaptive triggers uh
with like a first person shooter that
you just do not get on any other
controller and i think it
it adds so much to the play experience
for me
um it really feels like like a next-gen
experience like like this evolution
of like how you can like use shooters um
and like when you turn it off like you
immediately can tell the difference
just like oh like there's no feedback uh
to any of this at all
yeah it's it's it's really wild um
like it it's kind of thing where you're
like man i want every game to use this
um and
because it just it enhances the game in
a super tangible
super meaningful way and
it definitely like as someone who plays
on pc i have a high-end gaming pc
i love my xbox um but like
the controller alone is what's making me
want to play on playstation
um and that's wild that is such a that's
a thing i wasn't expecting to say
um but of course some games don't use it
super well like i i've been playing
godfall i don't think
uh godfall uses the like triggers super
well
um because like you're like hammering
the heavy attack
and the like resistance is kicking in
yeah and it's hard to push on it
multiple times in a row
but it only kicks in when you push it
multiple times in a row so
it's a little weird in some games but uh
when it's used well
holy crap it is a really cool controller
it is developer
you know uh implemented so it really
depends on how they do it
um i think call of duty is like a great
first example
um obviously like they've they've kind
of been like big on the marketing with
with the playstation so i imagine like
there was some sort of like incentive to
do it well for them um but i mean it's
also like
this is like the first attempt at a
shooter
so i'm like i'm so curious to see
hold on um
you're welcome i'm so curious to see
like how
developers can get even better with it
and you know like improve
the feedback and make it more more
subtle and more
more reactive um no arguments here
because like oh yeah for a first attempt
this feels
feels really good yeah i'm really
excited to play it
it seems uh it seems really cool and
obviously like the adaptive triggers the
first thing you think of is oh i want to
see what a shotgun feels like
um the single shot this rifle here like
it has like
this like really like you have to really
like pull the trigger
you know like there's a real weight to
the trigger here
that is freaking cool it feels really
cool
all clear um so on twitch we have some
questions how does quick resume work
with disc games so no quick resume
um but on the xbox uh quick resume you
would have to switch the discs
to do that yeah um and i'm and i'm not
100 sure how that
works if if the games if disc games do
actually
like quick resume um once the disc is in
uh so darth vader on twitch
you can put a ps4 this game in uh
install it
but if you want to play it you have to
keep that disc in yeah
uh your hdmi cables will work with the
ps5 but if you
have an hdmi 2.1 tv uh you will need a
hdmi 2.1 cable yes uh i can't show so
for right here you'll see uh 120 refresh
rate disabled
granted that only takes place in
multiplayer in this game but um i can't
even show that
uh because of my graphics card or my
capture card
isn't even capable of uh doing that
so i'm just getting subtitles on i
realize i didn't have those on
uh so hdmi 2.1 offers a lot of different
things
um variable refresh rate which the ps5
does not utilize yet
um it does stuff like uh you can
have yc444 hdr
120 hertz 4k uh and in k
it's capable of doing 8k and 60. but uh
yeah i i would not expect that
uh they say they can do it but i i don't
think they're gonna i don't think that's
gonna be a thing that you see regularly
i hope not i agree i really hope not and
i
hope the industry i don't know like
it depends on if if people want to buy
18 tvs i guess and that's going to
decide
if we see a ps5 pro
but right now i i don't i don't know
that we'll see a ps5 pro because
like hdmi 2.1 is just starting to be a
thing
uh there are like a handful of tvs that
support it
uh and it's it's
it's not really um
something that you that you you need to
worry about like i i just i don't think
8k is
i mean i i didn't think 4k was was a big
deal and i still don't
but it's nice to have and it looks great
um
like 1440p is is like the resolution in
my opinion
um but hey
we're at 4k and games are running really
well at it so i'm i'm fine as long as
as long as the games are running well
like i can't complain all right matt
um i've been informed by tay that um my
obs
got weird and actually we've been
streaming at 720p 30. so hold on
folks i'm gonna fix that for y'all
because uh that is that's unacceptable
that is unacceptable we'll stop for just
a second uh
please stand by okay
we should be back hey all right we're
back
uh cool apologies about that let's
get back to the game here yeah what's up
i did say 1440p uh i think i think 1440p
is the best because it it's like
especially on pc it is the best of both
like performance and graphics
and i like i like it i agree and i'm i'm
kind of bummed that tvs
uh sorry i skipped over it for the most
part um
like technically tv's do you support it
as far as like
being used as like an uh adopted as a
standard resolution you don't really see
that
yeah it also like i i think 1440p looks
great on a 4k tv
as well oh yeah um i've i play my pc on
my 4k tv at 1440p
that's what i do uh dlss if it's
available for the specific game
but uh
i cannot complain uh no that's how i do
it too because it's like 4k
just like it takes up too much
horsepower
to get running smooth 1440p you can you
can run that
smooth all day and it looks great
what is the 3d audio like
uh you can tell a difference from normal
audio um
i so so this differing opinion some of
my co-workers like it a lot
um for me i i don't think uh i like
it's really hard to criticize because
it it comes with the console it works
with all of your headphones so it's not
like you have to buy anything extra
um to take advantage of it
so so it it's fine i i don't think it's
amazing this is a really cool map by the
way
oh yeah yeah yeah we haven't barely
photographed it it's like oh this is
like a nuke town you're like oh yeah
you're in like a rushing training ground
there's a burger town reference uh this
is nuke city dude
uh there's there was like an arcade
earlier that had a bunch of um
references to old activision arcade
games like there's some uh
cool [ __ ] in this game uh so so yeah
like 3d audio
it works i'm really curious to use it
with this
because uh first person games really
take advantage of it well especially in
like multiplayer
because like i'll use like creative
super x5 or
razer's thx spatial audio um
to like more accurately hear people
sneaking up on me or like hearing people
like
flanking me from outside of the house
um yeah it it's fine like like
i i don't think it's revolutionary
uh in the way it maybe sounded like they
were kind of pitching it to me
yeah um i'm i agree i'm with you i
i want to test out more too uh because
of
as you said it only works with
headphones um
and because of the nature of the
playstation if you plug in headphones it
diverts all audio to those headphones
and uh i have to be capping these games
a lot um i can't use
the 3d audio um when i'm capping so i
haven't been able to like
really properly like try it out uh
specifically with this game in
multiplayer but
um over the weekend when i when i don't
have to worry about capping i can just
play
on my own i want to try it right how i
feel about it uh
let's see um
uh resident evil 8 or sorry i don't mean
do a fan cap code resident evil village
uh is
it i'd be interested to see how that
uses radio audio uh
3d audio because uh that seems to be
like
really holding it on playstation
uh they've been saying like oh it's
gonna have the 3d audio and it's going
to have
this yeah so that'll be cool because
especially since that that werewolf
thing is
is going to be following you uh
it'll be following you it's it's not
chasing you or anything it's just
it just wants to go where you're going
um
what's this guy up to these guys suck
they're like
heavy dudes so basically oh my god
uh i love it but yeah it's uh
it's it's
it's exciting to think of it being used
really well
but so far not super essential
um what question do we have here i had
another question
uh you can you can stream to twitch
youtube from the ps5 uh they have a new
camera i haven't tested it a whole lot
just because streaming went up yesterday
uh and um
they have a new camera and you can like
like i was reading up on it
and they say you can like eliminate the
um background kind of like you do in the
zoom or something like that oh yeah and
so it
hopefully will look cooler like it'll
look more like a professional stream
than it did on the ps4 um so
i'd love to try that out that sounds
really cool
can you play on uh monitor on 120 frames
per second
yes so yes
yeah yeah yeah it needs to support it
and also uh
yeah it's it's a it's it's a little more
complicated than just
hey will my tv just support everything
plugging it in yeah yeah and
and and these tvs still have like weird
i think it's gonna be a while before
like uh looks like every tv is kind of
like supporting stuff and there's
there's kinks worked out i mean
uh you and me were talking about an
issue that rtv has
rtv is like that new lg cx and it's like
the one that has
all the bells and whistles it has the
you know
2.0 with 120 support it has the vrr has
all this stuff but um
uh i was getting a weird flickering
issue when i was trying to use variable
refresh rate on
my xbox series x the other day um
and it seems like it's apparently an
issue with the tv
uh so i have to have it turned off for
the moment um which is a bummer
that really sucks uh so i think i think
tv
manufacturers are still still working
out the kinks on a lot of this stuff
this a lot of this tech is really new
so um it's really cool that like the new
consoles support them out of the box
but i think it might still be a little
bit before this stuff
is universal and when working flawlessly
uh the leviathan no
uh 3d audio needs to be supported by the
game specifically
yes um which is a little bit of a bummer
because um
like other 3d audio technologies like
are able to just like work with anything
specifically on the pc
um like dolby atmos i think also needs
to be supported
um but it's a little it's a little bit
of
of a bummer that you can't like apply
that to resident evil 7
yeah if there's something that i i hope
that uh
sony updates on their store that they
don't really have is i think they should
add a section that has a checklist of
like
hey this game has 120 yes mode
this game supports 3d audio their store
does not say any of that information you
have to find all of that from um
third party you know like searching
yourself which i think kind of sucks
so i i would like to see that be a more
universally supported thing on their
their store page same with um if uh
ps4 games get ps5 updates there's really
no good way to tell
um if your game got like a patch that
like enhances it in any way
um you you basically just have to rely
on
again like third party like tweets from
developers that say like hey that latest
patch added
uh enhancements that improve your
experience on the ps5
yeah yeah totally it it honestly it
would be easy just do it kind of like
how the switch does these are the
controllers you can use
yeah exactly and it's like like just
just hit us with like hey this has
um this uses adapted triggers this does
i mean
that might be a little more difficult
but 3d audio is one of those things that
you can definitely
i think 3d audio is one that they should
definitely do and i think stuff like 120
and uh yeah batman's would be a good one
that would be good
uh
yeah just just just whatever the game
supports
the leviathan um uh but also stereo
audio
is not is not bad like i now
like it like a solid pair of stereo
headphones
um can sound surround
um as it is so i wouldn't worry too much
about it
um it more depends on your headphones
than anything
uh but uh but yeah i would not worry
about 3d audio not being supported by
red dead
yeah i don't i don't think it's gonna um
it's not gonna be a huge huge detriment
the the if if there's anything that i
would like games to go back in and uh
adapt it would actually be the the um
dual sense
features uh over the 3d audio
um but that's a lot of work so i don't
know if i don't really expect that to
ever happen
uh to be honest right uh
no i haven't noticed any overheating um
nope
i uh i i've noticed sound but the only
time i hear
sound from the ps5 is when i am playing
a disc game
uh or um and the disc game
usually only makes sound when it's like
revving up
to like start and once it calms down i
don't really hear it much
uh hard drives will make noise obviously
but that's that's just
can't be avoided because that's the hard
drive itself um
but uh like the external hard drive um
but yeah it it it's a very quiet system
it seems like a cool system
hey man matt i just shot that guy let's
party dude
yeah go down what
sorry to cut you off i just was no man i
i saw that too i was like hey man
that guy likes to party dude what can
you say
uh does the ps5 have themes not yet uh
or
we don't know if it will but it
definitely does not have at the moment
which sucks because i have these dancing
skeletons that i would love to bring
over
it it's weird though like the the you i
could
i could kind of should talk about after
the this mission's over but like the way
the ui is set up i don't really know if
themes would like work
because like the games you're hovering
on like take up the full
screen it's like right yeah inside of
like
changing the color when you're in the um
like the system menu like i don't really
know
or the buttons like the actual icons
yeah yeah maybe that but like for the
most part it's like
those things don't really work the same
way they did on the ps4
yeah that's very true um but hopefully
like they give you some selection um it
looks fine as it is
um i definitely would like i
i don't know that we need ps4 themes
um but something would be nice i need to
be able to bring over my princess diana
theme
on the ps4 yeah uh i and i have of
course have my dancing skeletons uh but
i also have a dubstep rabbit
and some other really dumb stuff
real dumb themes if you've never like
gone on the playstation store and just
look at the themes they have available
oh boy it is a cottage industry
of weird [ __ ]
uh according to lima's tech tips a lot
of those aftermarket you know what's
funny i actually live
not too far from linus um we we are from
the same city
um yeah not all of them are great
not a lot not all 3d audio is great but
i really like super x5
um super x5 basically just makes it
sound like you're listening to like a
surround sound system
in your headphones and it doesn't
degrade the audio which is
is really nice um and that is the
problem with my job is i'm testing a lot
of headphones and headsets
so i don't get to use my favorites all
the time
um but uh super x5 is great i i i'm a
huge fan
um we saw them at ces this year jean-luc
and i
and we're very impressed
yeah yeah i thought that stuff was very
impressive uh the
ps5 dual sense will not well i mean so
if it works on pc uh you can plug it
into your pc and try it
um it will not have the same
functionality
in the vast majority of games
um i i like i know sometimes when you
plug into dual sense
you'll get like icons for ps4
but like these are like very specific
ps5 features
that they would specifically need to
program into the pc game
okay and uh i don't see that happening
well anyway gentlemen i think that was a
good time to call it
on call of duty yeah the mission was
almost over but i could just call it
there honestly
um uh we could move on their game i
think
people yeah stuff honestly do you want
to move on to uh
the the show stopper yeah what's that
what's the show stopper
well take a guess man and if you don't
get it right you have to leave the
stream
you have to give me the controller
um it's not astro
even though that is one of the best
games on this platform
um
uh souls demon souls right
that's my hint um let's do let's do
the demon souls maybe i could beat the
tower knight uh we can try that
hey forgi calgary canada nice
i hope you like our canucks that we sent
you over the
off season god uh calgary canucks baby
um yeah the
uh someone was asking earlier about um
oh god what was i gonna say oh astro
if they should play astro before they um
before they do anything else you don't
have to astro is is
i definitely think booting it up first
is the way to go
um try out that controller demo see how
the controller works
um but dude just just play it whatever
you want man astro is an outstanding
game it's
really fantastic fun little uh fun
little platformer
it's one of my favorite games of the
year it is a lot of fun i would have
paid
money for that thing uh and the fact
that it's free with your console
absolutely wild all right i think we're
just gonna keep on my
my current save um unless people really
want to see the beginning of the game
again but i imagine a lot of that has
been
shown uh yesterday when people were like
streaming and putting up video
uh how's how's little big planet uh so
sac boy
a big adventure it's not little big plan
at all it's like a
3d mario uh
platformer uh i i enjoy it quite a bit
it's it's not
super challenging um it's not
um
it's not it's not quite as good as a
mario game but there are some really
clever things that games go
doing and uh i'm really enjoying it
it's really cute it is it is shockingly
cute
uh oh we're at the same place charlotte
i i just got i beat the felix
the phalanx last night and i was like
what the hell is this thing i i did that
uh
i did that classic uh classic dark souls
thing where um i got to the tower night
first try
got him all the way down to one hit left
first try got two cocky
got myself killed oh wow you got wait
you did the
the tower night yeah um holy [ __ ] dude
but i i lost on my first try because i
is this the hockey is the tower knight
is in the first level
uh he's in one two oh so so are you on
oh you're in one two right now i'm in
one two right now oh okay
so this is like after the phalanx right
right okay that makes sense
and and then afterwards every time i try
to fight him i lost
and that's it's just like yep this is
classic from software behavior right
here
um uh so
uh mario will will always be better than
sac boy uh
it was your conclusion no that that's
just what i'm seeing in the chat
uh sackboy is very fun very charming
um good co-op game oh my god with a
split screen
for kids i i i think that game will do
really
really great things with kids because it
is something i really appreciate about
the ps5
lineup is they have a really good
variety yeah everyone it seems
it is and like the fact that they were
able to get all of this to line up
even with the pandemic and everything
like
it's really impressive uh and obviously
there are some features that i can like
tell are missing from the ps5 like the
like the media remote has a microphone
button on it
but there's no voice assistant so if you
push the microphone on the media remote
and talk nothing happens um
so it's not it's not like a fire stick
whoa dude
it's not like a fire stick um where you
talk into the remote and then
it shows you the movie you want to watch
uh yet anyway hopefully that gets added
that would be really good
in that grass uh if you buy the disc
version of the ps5
you will be able to play all of your ps4
games yeah yeah uh not
not the ones that aren't supported there
there is a small list
comparatively um but uh it is it is
definitely
um possible
waiting for him to come back around
damien antonelli says the ds5
got the ds5 the dual sense
uh does operate my ps3 system menus when
plugged in that's dope
oh that's interesting uh that's pretty
cool
yeah yeah actually 14 makes a good point
um
sac boy is one of the few local
multiplayer games
and i think it's exclusively local
multiplayer
uh i think they're adding in online
later oh
cool okay from what i remember don't
quote me on that but i'm pretty sure i
saw a thing about like that's coming
coming a little later um but yeah right
yes you're right it does have a split
screen
oh john luke you're not here anymore
what do you mean
your webcam is missing my webcam is
missing oh hold on
that's weird oh i know what happened
my my camera's battery died
nice that that
i don't know if you can hear me still
i'm going to keep talking i noticed your
your camera was going out of focus and i
thought it was just auto focusing
um so to see that it was just dying is
pretty funny
oh that is odd net person i i have not
experienced that
right damien that is interesting um
i haven't experienced that uh hey
jean-luc how does your controller feel
when pressing the bottom half of
x or triangle bottom half
yeah does it feel like mushy like it's
not hitting properly or does it doesn't
even feel different
does it feel different to me yeah i
haven't noticed that it feels pretty
like it doesn't feel like something you
could rock back and forth
it feels very solid yeah i remember that
being a thing with the um
ps3 controller especially i felt like
they got pretty mushy
but no i haven't i haven't experienced
that that's a good question though
fortune you got to launch xbox and it
arrived broken what do you mean
that that's awful yeah that's terrible
i'm so sorry
uh my my xbox is having an issue where
when i turn it on the controller
sometimes doesn't work
um so i wonder what that's about but
hopefully that's not what broken means
my mine
is the disk drive on mine is very loud
when i was installing yakuza
because i bought that game on disc um
oh mine wasn't that's weird oh gosh
um but when i started the game up it was
fine
oh god hold on this
i'm in a is spot note like like i think
i think damian i'm thinking like when we
push down on the bottom
of the button it still feels like we're
pushing straight on is what
jumbo saying yeah i could grab
i could grab a controller but it's on
the other side of the room right now
oh dude dude i parried the guy and it
was about to do the attack and then the
judge
set us on fire the dragon said get
good oh that was funny holy [ __ ]
all right fire your bolt that's like
when you perform an execution in call of
duty and someone shoots the guy you're
executing
yeah god
oh that was too funny this has been
going great
uh this is spelling good things for this
tower night fight
i'm about to have all right come on come
on
there we go nice and smooth that's what
i'm looking
yeah the funny thing about i i've been
playing this game and it's really
awesome um
it it it's so weird like
it's demon souls i've played demon souls
you have played the original demon souls
i i haven't played all of it
but i played like the first couple areas
okay
um and then i i was getting motion sick
because of my
my current tv and the ps3 did not play
well together
um but
um it's
it's from software game and this is a
firm software game but this looks
and and like operates not like a from
software game at all times like
like npc's talk and their mouths move
and they have the time half the time
their mouths move some some of the oh
really yeah that's interesting the
maiden doesn't uh
her mouth didn't move sometimes oh yeah
something dude i
did not realize her eyes were like that
that was that was concerning and also i
had some thoughts but
um it it i was like whoa the maiden
looks
really good but also horrifying
i'm i'm very happy so far with the art
direction of this game
yeah me too it it feels good
why don't you show some of the filters
are you playing on classic right now i'm
playing uh no i'm playing on og
um but i could i could turn on the
classic filter
yeah let's let's take a look at some of
the filters just show this stuff we're
running on performance by the way i'm
yeah
show them plans you're not gonna flip
you're not gonna flip it over just to
show them i'll flip it over to show them
but i'm not gonna play
this fight on that because uh yeah that
would be rough so here's classic
um which is kind of adds that green
filter that you're used to if you played
the original game um
it's not going to make it look exactly
like it obviously but i do think it is
is a nice touch
this is also running on cinematic mode
which is
uh as you can probably see very
um yeah not it's a lot more like
i think tam was saying it's it's true to
the original game
yeah ironically it's true to the
original game in that regards which is
funny
but uh yeah let's just say like i don't
you shouldn't i don't think you should
play the game in this in this mode
uh no and to like hey a lot of ps5 games
are defaulting to performance which is
nice to see yes like they want you to
play it
and hey guess what turns out playing at
a high frame rate makes games look
better
way better like visually even
yeah yeah when i was uh i was checking
out spider-man
remastered and um at first i put it on
uh fidelity mode which is the graphics
mode and the opening cut scene
it was kind of jittery and it was like
hard to read like the newspaper
clippings on peter's wall
so we switched it over to performance
and then it was like buttery smooth
it was like oh this is a way better
experience yeah from our testings from
my testing so far at least i can't speak
for jean luke
um spider-man remastered seems less uh
optimized than miles morales it
definitely doesn't feel as
it's very smooth in performance but i
have noticed a few drops where
miles morales didn't yeah
yeah for sure here's the one reborn
fight
oh yeah that that's um i'm very looking
forward to like people who've played
every other souls game but not
dementials to just realize that from
software has basically been recycling
demon souls fights
for the entire career of the soul series
i'm just like wait a minute you mean all
of this just came from james souls
it's like yep yep always has been
god there there and and like
so many like so many developers could
not get away with it
but like from software just makes such
excellent games that it's like
i don't think i hate him for it i love
it
oh i'm really stoked uh
to keep playing this man it's so much
fun uh i i think i think the ps5 really
hit it
hit it home with these uh exclusives at
launch um
and and like i don't understand when
people say the launch titles suck like i
i think like
assassin's creed watchdogs uh
this game spider-man sack boy
astro uh even on the even on the xbox
here's x yakuza is the only next-gen
version
oh man he got smoked i got i got shot by
an arrow walls getting back up that was
hey congratulations fight night on cap'n
oh sorry copying here ps5
uh let's see
god
hey bob jones
how's it going man
watch dogs legion better than watch dogs
too i like it a lot better than watch
dogs too
but uh i know some people don't watch
dogs legion doesn't really have uh
as cohesive a story or like
cast um it's kind of just what you make
of it
um i almost wish watchdogs legion didn't
have a story
like it kind of doesn't like
at least from what i've played so far
it's kind of just like hey go do this go
do that go do this go to that
there's a bad guy uh have you played
much of that john luke
i haven't touched uh watchdogs at all
yet
i like it a lot i i got a john wick guy
and i've been smoking everyone with my
gun coda it's so cool
walking up to someone doing like stealth
attacks you do like a john wick like
gunkata move and you just like murder
you just
shoot them directly into that it stinks
everyone's like oh i'm playing
non-lethal it's like oh i'm playing
very least extremely lethal
i'm playing all lethal right now uh
because it is like
so much fun
uh
is this bloodborne two uh this is
bloodborne
point five jacob decker
you snarky bastard
uh jacob
what's what's the status on your ps5 man
jacob
jacob decker everybody in the chat
our our beloved one of our beloved video
producers
i like to call him jacob pecker be nice
to him
yep inappropriate inappropriate behavior
he be nice to the chat only i'm allowed
to be mean to jake
uh frame rate uh if it looks a little
choppy it might be the stream
um because if my frames are dropping at
all but it is
impressive you look good on my end no
yeah yeah performance is pretty smooth
maybe maybe reset if you're
if it's being a little choppy for you
but the game yeah
smooth the game is very smooth
uh you're welcome yakuo we're glad to be
playing
ah damn yeah jake says he's not getting
his until next week
uh same same here i mean i i have my ps5
from the review but i bought one for my
for my brother uh as a congratulations
for
going to school and uh it's it's not
coming in until
monday at the earliest um
very very uh very you know it's
disappointing man
it's a weekend it's a it's a long
weekend for some people so
you want them games right yeah it's it's
it's like oh man like you get your hopes
up and then obviously when it doesn't
happen it's like god damn that's
that is disappointing hey luke
does this does this have uh multiplayer
uh
d missiles yeah yes yeah
did the original it did oh wow
it was awesome it was like broken yeah
broken as in uh not broken isn't like
non-functional broken as in like
the uh pvp like weapon builds were
so in the game that like right it was
you could troll there's literally a
weapon in this game that um
removes people's levels so you can just
absolutely destroy somebody's day uh and
i'm very curious if they balanced any of
that at all
oh yeah fortune i bought mine from best
buy canada too
canada post is usually pretty decent
with best buy around here because i live
pretty close to a best buy warehouse
like
within 20 minutes i think and
uh but yeah that my mine is mine is in
a city not far from me and i don't i
don't know why uh
it's gonna take till monday of all
things i i you know what sean luke i'm
gonna say this
um i i i was like okay hey consoles
might not come launch date today
but because the console makers aren't
launching on a friday
you still have a very good chance of
getting it before the weekend
but yeah it doesn't seem to be the case
this time which is a bummer
um
understandable like even without a
pandemic that would be understandable
but
um uh
yeah it is it is definitely
disappointing
okay i just gotta get rid of these guys
thank you that's the move i wanted you
to do
okay okay oh all right okay we're still
good we're still fine
all right if you don't beat this guy
shame i'm gonna be yeah i agree
nice oh wow dude that does not do a lot
of damage
i don't know it's it doesn't i'm using
you for strats dude
yeah you'll learn what to do and what
not to do
yeah i i did not i did not fight this
guy in the original game so
okay and i'm also playing really bad
you got this
uh how much will the online cost same
same as it was on ps4 uh
ps plus uh transfers over except on the
ps5
you get a uh collection of ps4 games
that you can play on the ps5 including
days gone
which has a next-gen update which looks
really great
um so if you've wanted to try days gone
um which i wanted to do i i
did not think it looked great when it
launched um
and i tried it on the ps5 and it's it's
it runs really well that's that's as
much i can say about
it um and it's not it's not too bad of a
game
it's it's pretty decent but um
especially when you have so much to play
on the ps5 um
it might not be at the top of your list
nice smack them up
okay take it easy take it easy
that's the move that's the move that
sucks don't don't let that move happen
and then oh wow he just slapped
okay that's the that's the good news the
aoe moves easy to dodge
we still have the classic filter on
right yes
nice you should turn on another filter
in the middle of this boss fight
yeah i can do that no not in the middle
of the boss fight
after after this is over
thoughts on horizon forbidden um
excited so we the we've got a podcast
going live friday but i talk about this
a bit on that
um gamespot after dark listen every
friday
we've got a great uh next-gen debate
episode
um that uh that may not have been as
much of a debate as some people
have thought but but we definitely talk
about the new consoles
um and uh
the interesting thing about the ps5
exclusives is that there are a lot more
known quantities about the ps5
exclusives
like with the ps4 it was kind of a
a toss-up like we just didn't know it
was gonna happen but sony
let a lot of studios like reinvent
their franchises and that paid off in
dividends like people love the ps4
exclusives
um the ps5 definitely is like okay
another horizon
another spider-man another god of war
uh we're not sure what naughty dog is
doing but you can probably take a guess
um
you can probably take a guess of what
type of game that will be anyway
uh it'll be a shooter and it'll have
cutscenes a lot of them
um oh man they're bringing it back
they're making a
uh well what's that fighting game they
made
last of us curt uh wave the warrior
yes they'll make a way on the way too
god that'd be cool
that'd be really cool um
yeah i uh
i i definitely uh am looking forward to
playing a lot of these ps4 exclusives
sorry ps5 exclusives um but it is
it is not as like ooh what is this going
to be like like oh
like there's not as much mystique to it
which is uh not disappointing per se but
it is like all right yeah like
the ps5 will have a lot of great
exclusives like the ps4 did
uh where xbox comes in it's like oh wow
we don't really know what's gonna happen
um with bethesda with ninja theory with
obsidian with all these studios they
purchased
um it is exciting to think of what they
are gonna come up with
um so yeah both consoles
look like they have bright futures and
if the xbox could pull off what the ps4
did
uh which the ps4 started off slow um
and then like picked up steam like
nothing else so
uh it is it is an exciting time to be a
gamer for sure
i agree
yeah even just compared to like you said
compared to the ps
ps4 though like there are there are like
a good amount of games at launch to play
i feel like i have a lot of options
right now in terms of oh yeah games to
play which i feel like i did not have
when i bought my ps4 at launch
i remember the great thing about the ps5
um
sorry you keep going oh no i was just
gonna say i remember playing like
assassin's creed and kill zone and then
i was like
all right and then you were like all
right waiting till thief
and then thief came out and it was thief
and you were like yeah that's
pretty much i guess i'm waiting till
titanfall
um yeah so i i definitely
like i've talked to jake about the talk
to everyone about this
where it's like last generation
it was those games and you're all right
i'm done uh oh i guess i'll play batman
arkham origins on my old console
i guess i'll play south park on my old
console
um but this time around it's like hey
unless something really bad happens um
you can play those games on your ps5 and
your xbox series x
um and that's awesome uh like
the actual optimized games are great
but um hey
cyberpunk comes out in a month and it'll
be playable on both like
that's awesome
you can unplug your ps4 and i recommend
it
unless you want to play assassin's creed
syndicate
which is not compatible with the ps5
uh yeah jake uh
jake yeah uh yeah john speaking to the
ui earlier uh jake
pointed out too uh that's what i'm
saying
it it it's like it's it is a from
software game but it just doesn't look
like one i don't like the ui
it's the one thing so far that i don't
like it feels
it's like functional but they like they
took all the character out of it
there's like no character yeah it and it
looks flat to me like it doesn't look
it's very flat like i'm not
not that ui is diegetic ever but like it
doesn't
look like it fits exactly
um you know i'm not going to say like
that original demonstration like perfect
it was pretty ugly
actually but like there was like a
character to its ugliness that i like
really like that i just this lacks
like this is like you know
function over form uh to like an extreme
in my opinion
um yeah here go to the pause menu
quickly oh actually wait until
that guy's dead yeah like you show like
the um
this looks like kingdoms of a vomiter
like this
this looks bad yeah yeah i'm not
this that these are okay
i guess this looks familiar
yeah yeah it's bland it's not
it's pretty it's pretty bland but the
rest of the game like
i'm into it for sure too and that's what
makes it honestly
it makes the ui more jarring is because
the rest of the game you're like wow
they put so much love and detail into
the
into this and then i'm just looking at
the ui and i'm like i really don't want
to be like
mean to the ui people like you know i'm
sure they work very hard on it but it's
just like
it's not quite there it's not there for
me it's not it yeah
yeah and like and also like at some
point where
it's not as important as the rest of the
game and and
as far as we've played like they seem to
have nailed
sure uh the game part so yeah
the game feels perfect i have no
qualms with the gameplay so far
damn bro oh yeah jake points out uh
remember when xbox exclusives all had
that like same
mobile looking ui oh
yeah yeah yeah yeah
and then um god uh ea games had
that same like it was it was like this
this like
xbox 360 like design but it was it was
definitely very
mobile looking this weird like cookie
cutter kind of
yeah um yeah
yeah all the sports games did that and
yeah it's one of those things that
you're like you understand from like a
business
like company perspective of like oh you
know like it's all like
uniform into the brand and you're saving
time but it's just like
people like to play with their phones
yeah it creates
what if we put it on the console
everything looks the same and you're
like oh my god
yeah it's it's no good
what uh what build are you gonna be
playing in this joan luke
uh this is uh i'm not really sure where
i'm gonna go with this build
um i'm just playing good old
good old night right now uh because
royals for babies
who are bad at video games hell yeah
dude that's not true you can play royal
if you want
um that's funny i i i was i
i was like hey i want to play uh
i want to play this this remake as a
knight so i was playing as a royal in
demon souls and i did not know that that
was a thing but the magic is very good
so yeah yeah yeah so that makes sense
for those who don't know
like royal was always considered like
the beginner mode because
magic and demon souls is like actually
um pretty varied and
uh overpowered in a lot of cases and i
actually really like that about it like
i i honestly think it has the best magic
system of any of the souls games
and um their solution in like the later
souls games was just to kind of like
get rid of a lot of the magic um rather
than like tweak it
um which i always thought was kind of a
shame so i feel like this is the only
game where you can like truly go like
full magic build
so i if you want to do that like i
highly encourage that i was like joking
when i said
it's for babies like don't don't
actually uh think that
at all and there are a lot of really
cool um
spells in this game and i actually am i
kind of do want to play like a royal
build just because i want to actually um
see how those like look in this game in
the remake
um yeah i i'm i'm gonna play royal
in my second playthrough for sure
yeah but uh i'm trying to do a quality
build
but uh right now i'm focusing on
strength
um i i i like quality for my first
playthrough in these games
because it lets me kind of like do both
strength and dex weapons
uh and then i get to mess around with
all of the different weapons
and find out what i want to do in the
next one yeah
so for people watching i i'm doing
strength and skill
kind of leveling them the same that's
kind of what i'm doing right now
uh so basically i'm just focusing on um
uh vitality endurance strength and skill
trying to get my my weight my weight
load down so i can
roll nicely yep
yep that's a big one
i just need to get these last two guys
here
just gotta watch out for him stuff
there we go okay
oh there's still a guy left it's two
guys left
uh so ps plus collection saves um works
just like the ps4
um except you do have to go into the
system settings to get your
uh your like cloud saves yeah it doesn't
take a minute
yeah it doesn't take download um
uh hey silver nasty why don't you chill
out dude um
and also
how does game run on a 1080p monitor um
just like you're seeing here except in
1080p um
probably no benefits because it's i
don't think this game's
well i i can't say really but i imagine
this game does not output
1080p on a 1080p monitor it would just
super sample or actually you know maybe
it does super sample down to 1080p
i don't know that's a good question i'm
not sure
do not know how i avoided that so what's
the plan here genre how are you gonna
punish this dude well i'm gonna not do
that
so does he is he like this the entire
fight or do you like
weaken him at some point so the trick is
basically to keep hitting
see him as as that there's some [ __ ]
happening to his legs as i'm hitting
them
oh yeah it's it's going bad yeah you
want you want to keep doing that
basically all right cool
are there any other games people want to
check out we we have access to uh
uh assassins creed spider-man sac boy
um how much sack boy have you played
john luke
uh only a couple levels um have you
gotten to the uh the dmca level that
would that would get us taken down
uh i don't think so i'm not hurt
sure i don't i don't know exactly which
level that is to be honest i i kind of
want to play it
uh and if we're talking over it like i
don't see it being a big deal but
i don't know
what is the greatest launch game you've
ever played john luke it's a launch game
i've ever played
um amp 3 on the xbox 360.
it's a pretty good one
the man that's a hard question
the boring answer is halo
i say that's someone who really loves
halos just that's like yeah
i think the best launch game ever uh
astro boy is up there astro boy astros
playroom
astros playroom is up there um
it is it is a it is a delight it is it
is such a great
launch game in the purest sense of that
word is just
just just beautiful just beautiful
uh people people yeah maybe you can show
off assassin's creed for a bit after
this
sure sure um
ben says hell yeah m3
yeah ben knows what's up if there's
anyone on this planet that would
also appreciate amp 3 the way i do it
would be ben
fogey bear says the labels are scanning
no one is safe from dmca
which is a bummer because that level is
so cool
oh okay okay okay
oh no
you broke his ankles man come on come on
oh dude oh
oh that sucked my stamina
anyway so that's how you do it you
basically knock knock his ass down and
then you hit him in the head
then you dunk on him then you dunk on
him yeah that
that setup did not go as well as i
wanted but uh
we'll keep at it
uh alvin bates we have uh we have some
astro videos on
on our youtube channel if you want to go
check those out
uh though i i recommend uh waiting to
play it for yourself if you're getting a
ps5
because it is uh it is a delight
to see for the first time i agree on
your own
oh yeah breath of the wild i forgot
about that one oh yeah breath of wild
is a pretty pretty damn good launch game
uh yeah that's that's that's a good one
sonic 1 sega mega drive
mario 64 launch game
mario 64 was a launch game yeah that it
was that in pilot wings
that's a good one uh wait
yeah that sounds right um
sac boy assassin's creed seem to be a
big one
there we go uh
i i would like to show there's one very
specific thing i would like to show
about spider-man oh nice shot
[ __ ] him up slap that stupid knight
oh don't do that move oh you suck
it's the one move i don't like anytime
he does that or the sweet
i'm always like get the [ __ ] out of here
damn
these these legs look freaking like
like the flash little like
right now the flash doesn't have the
wings on his feet
hermes or whatever i don't know it looks
listen it looks it looks cool
if if they made jordans that look like
this i would be
that's right just keep doing that move
over and over again
oh get out of the way oh no
that sucks that sucks that sucks
oh no john luke
nope don't risk it don't risk it get out
of there the hell out get hello
man that placement was the worst
oh my god dude
that's right do that again
do that jump
almost there
oh he's gonna do it he's gonna do it
yep oh [ __ ]
oh he does not like that dude
you might actually be able to just like
take him out by slashing his ankles
that'd be really funny you're getting
really close
yeah it's gonna happen
man i i would have gone for it and not
so that's what i did that's why i did my
first yep i got him
nice hell yeah that happened to me the
first time i went for it and i died
that is awesome oh thank you uh
i haven't seen share play in any of the
settings unfortunately
sure play that's a good question
actually you can you can
definitely get a feed of your friend's
gameplay because then you can like
actually have it in the corner like a
little pit
uh i don't see anything
maybe go to uh maybe we should go to
your friends
um see the last five minutes
interesting well anyway unfortunately we
don't know at the moment
um but yeah that that's demon souls man
way to go dude yeah man let me just uh
let me cash in these souls
yeah let's show the uh let's show the
nexus
and then uh yeah we'll hop into
assassin's creed and people on
c uh yes that and sackboy but before we
go into those i want to show them
uh a spider-man thing real quick
uh yeah uh here's the nexus oh you don't
know what i can do i can show the
real quick the the photo mode oh yeah
yeah absolutely
so is this does this pause the game it
does i'm curious if people are gonna use
it to
manipulate the game at all yeah i was
going to say
this is the first paused menu they've
ever had
do the character you could turn off
their helmet or their weapon if you want
a bunch of different poses
wait keep going do they have the
do you oh i guess they couldn't do the
i was gonna say does he praise the son
praise the son no that's not from
no i was yeah i was gonna say well i
mean i was gonna see if they put it in
but then i realized oh they would
actually probably get in trouble if they
did that
well i mean it's uh they could do it i
think people just be like that's not
from this one um
yeah it's got like all your usual that's
from the other one
you can't do that uh
one cool thing is you can actually so
the filters we were talking about you
can mess with them
wow oh nice yeah let's go through them
so so you got your regular you got your
classic
vivid bright summer winter
evergreen monochrome antique
and then you can actually save your own
filter yeah right right
that's cool have a couple of uh options
uh then yeah some that is neat
it's a cool little photo mode um
which i'm excited to check out more
because i mean this game is just
absolutely beautiful
uh okay yeah let's uh
let's call it here yeah so pop pop back
to the home
oh yeah i guess you should save and exit
yeah i just wanna i don't know i assume
it does but i just
liked him yeah just to be safe um
so pop back the home go go to s
go to your main menu go to go over to
spiderman
which one don't uh red i want red
spiderman please okay no go
down uh
just just hit just hit resume i'll see
what happens i just want to show them
what happens
sure all right we're gonna hit resume
because someone asked about activities
and i said yeah you know what this is a
cool way to show this
in the game there you go in the game
really quick
new spider-man you know what i actually
can't come like i
hated this this peter parker dude like i
i i hated it when they announced it i
was like that's all peter
why do you change him i don't like
getting there at first but i'm i've
softened
to him yeah i played through miles
morales and i play and i've been playing
through this and it's like oh actually
i think this peter parker is better now
um but yeah you can hop out i just
wanted to show that but
they don't need you these nuts do not do
not spend time on this stream
yeah me too next next-gen commentary uh
is saying why didn't we discuss the
share options or even discuss the media
tab
awful dense review you should be ashamed
of yourselves
oh thanks next-gen commentary so the
reason why we couldn't discuss those
options
is because they weren't ready um
for launch um they were being worked on
um and not allowed to show
sony yeah been mad at us so so
maybe be a little nicer with your
internet comments
um but here you go we can show them now
i got youtube i got oh damn oh damn
disney plus and i got no damn oh damn
it's a media tab i don't know what else
to tell you
yeah it is exactly what you expect
exactly what you expect
you want to watch some naruto let's
watch some naruto yeah
it it it's like more like a fire stick
in terms of layout for this stuff but
yeah it's uh
i can surprise you can watch netflix on
this
cool like i do appreciate watching
netflix on the ps5 is a lot of fun
i have never had much more fun than
watching netflix on my ps5
the xbox is poopy with netflix this is
bad
if i did have to like actually be like
well what's better about it is like i do
appreciate that it actually is a
separate menu
from the game menu i also appreciate
that um
it actually just shows you um the most
recent ones you use
where on the ps4 it did not um so it's
actually easy it's quicker to get to the
specific apps you use yes so
i'll tell you what's cool about the
media section is that if you buy the
media remote and turn on your ps5 with
the media remote
actually um it's
it's uh it will go straight to the media
section
which is pretty damn nice
are you i'm i'm trying to do i'm going
to try to do the activity thing i want
to see
just this is way longer me stopping
to hold on this will be cool yeah let's
let's
shut the game down that is a bummer man
oh it doesn't do it for this one it
forces you into this that's a bummer
no no wait it didn't go to the menu it
is it is quicker
it is quicker okay because that is the
other one it went to the normally it'll
go to the main menu
this is still quicker okay they have
reduced
themselves that was still faster
[Laughter]
uh doesn't stream 4k
i don't think it streams 4k to a
a non 4k device so
they they do give no quick resume in the
ps5
no uh yeah i don't know about streaming
i do appreciate so the capture options
one you can choose whether
uh party audio is included in the um
in your like capture which i think is
really nice
oh yeah i super appreciate that and they
do give like 1080p or
um 4k if you want you can also change
uh if you want jpeg or png for your um
screenshots so more options and i do i
do appreciate that about it
the problem with recording at 4k is that
it takes a lot of space
and the ps5 does not have a lot of that
um
and as far as i know you can't save
recordings directly to an external hard
drive right um
not that i'm aware of you have to
transfer them
you have to transfer them so so the
here i could go out for a sec just to
show this um
uh you yeah we'll show the ps psn store
um yeah we can show the store um so for
storage i have console storage i have
extended storage
extended storage where i store all my
ps4 games
only lets me put games on it i can't put
anything else on it i can't put media on
it i can't put saves on it i can only
put
games on it um so this is basically
exclusively for playing my ps4 games on
uh if i want to have media and stuff
like that
um on something else i put in like a usb
stick
and then it just is like transferred to
usb but it doesn't save to the usb by
default you have to
manually transfer it every time you want
to do that so
yeah by default media the media gallery
does
just go to the uh main storage
uh by the way fun fact don't do this um
this is something that happened to me so
when because
i'm still playing the game right i pop
this up and it says hey hit resume
if i hit resume um oh in this game it
does it
okay this game got it right when i did
that on devil may cry
it restarted my my mission and
that was awesome almost all the way
through a level and i was like what
why would you do that it said resume and
i hit resume
assassin's creed correctly so that's
cool i guess that's a developer
by developer case of how they handle it
but be wary of that because devil may
cry screwed me over um
what are some of the things you think
are missing uh and hope they implement
in the future update
uh things like quick resume um storing
ps5 games on an external hard drive
would be nice
that's the big one i want it's the
external games
games on external hard drive because
needs it that
dude bandwidth man cap
expandable storage for sure it's coming
um
but right now at launch it is you can't
expand the storage
um so you would need to use an nvme
ssd to expand the storage but uh sony
needs to test them
to make sure they work with the console
um yeah
it's pretty disappointing that they
don't have there's currently no way
at launch to expand your internal
storage at all
um where xbox can especially since ps4
has less storage
than xbox by default
yeah i was a little disappointed when
they said they have an 825
gigabyte custom ssd i thought that was
them saying that's how much you can use
me too i assume like oh it's a thousand
and they're saying 800 but then it was
like yeah
no no 667 for games
it's like oh brother come on
and that's the thing is is uh it would
be wouldn't it be even less if they did
have quick resume because doesn't quick
resume have to take up a certain amount
of space for like the cache
uh assuming i'm understanding that
correctly sorry can you say that again
like if they had if ps5 had quick resume
doesn't doesn't the xbox use some of its
like storage
um as like a cache for to keep yeah
i think so so like yeah if this if this
had quick resume you'd have even less
storage space
yeah yeah it's uh we will see
i'm i'm not sure if it'll happen and
honestly i'm not
i'm not too sore about it
um i'm not either look at the quick
resume stuff
the loading is fast enough that it's
it's not too big of a deal
um freaking horse in this game there you
go
so uh another thing that i would like to
see is bluetooth
headphones support um
i prefer 2.4 gigahertz but bluetooth is
just nice to have especially when you
have like a nice pair of bluetooth
headphones you like
i agree uh
a voice assistant would be nice um
because the ps5 media remote has a
microphone that doesn't work
um something like that would be nice
uh yes you will be able to put in
nvme ssds uh gen four
fast gen four not like bottom line gen
4's but
like the ps5 is 5.5 gigabytes
per second read speed and you need
faster than that i believe to work with
the ps5
for expandable internal storage um
we just have to wait till sony posts
them and says hey these are the ones
that work
and uh also the ps5 is now updated to
use it
how are you supposed to
oh here one second i'm gonna i'm gonna
i'm gonna do something for the people at
home one second
i don't i don't know how you're supposed
to get this thing
i'm bizarre
ah i'll move on i want to be watch me
sit here trying to get
get gold
uh you have to play it off the desk if
you buy a ps4 game
and insert it into your ps5
yeah foggy i agree they should they
should have given you a bigger storage
option in my opinion
i agree i assume that's what uh
what brought down the it was probably a
price thing
on their end but oh yeah the consoles
would be a lot more expensive for sure
yeah uh yeah this game does look nice
now
i was playing it originally on the ps4
the ps4 version and i
was pretty disappointed how this game
looked
um i thought it like it looked really
washed out
uh it was kind of like low resolution uh
it was pretty choppy
um but having now checked out the ps5
version which is what i'm playing right
now
it's looking pretty sharp
are we friends on psn jean-luc uh
that's a good question what's up
let's uh
why don't you add me yeah
to make sure because like i want to see
if i can take control of your game
for uh game based
i'm just gonna send you
my username on discord
okay hold on yeah
i should probably go full cam for this
right yeah go full cam go full cam
okay give me give me a sec sorry folks
uh hey you guys we're gonna be testing
uh
shareplay now to see if it works um
i hope so
all right hit me with that uh
okay let's let's see yeah uh
nvme drives are expensive and to get the
fast enough drive you need to spend even
more money
how do i actually add friends on this i
bet this is
a new experience for me
when i do it from game base
oh no i am friends with you oh okay
what what's your name um
my it's just my last name oh you
is it because we're is it because my
setting is like
all like private and stuff uh if i went
to the bottom
i i saw you it says you're playing demon
souls
oh that's not supposed to be saying that
that's weird why
you wouldn't customize your privacy uh
anyone
wait what no
all right well you're friends with me so
for the moment we'll
i'll swap back i'll use all right yeah
yeah okay that sounds good that's that's
that's nice i like that i like that
we're friends
i like that we're friends too matt
all right let's go uh
let's go raid somebody
how's it going over there matt
i'm trying to find you trying to find me
maybe you can't find me because because
i have my settings turned off
oh
that might be it
well we weren't able to test this out
because i can't figure out why i can't
see jean-luc but um
if you take a look on
um on twitter at matt paget
at jean-luc seiby um we
we are testing stuff like this out all
the time so we'll probably
we'll probably test that and get back to
you
uh jean-luc let the people know how the
adaptive triggers and haptic
feels in this housing screen uh it feels
pretty
whatever there's
it doesn't feel all that different from
the ps4 version
to be honest i don't think they really
did much if anything with it
um like the adapter
the adaptive triggers cannot talk uh
basically do nothing
and the feedback just feels pretty on
point with what it was on the
ps4 which is disappointing so it's
definitely this is
a great case of like it really comes
down to
the developers properly utilizing that
stuff
um to enhance the experience as it were
oh [ __ ] we lit that house on fire um
but yeah i'm i'm kind of bummed i'm kind
of i was hoping playing the ps4 version
i was like man i hope that they uh
they do more with the uh
adapted triggers and have to feedback
but not really
that's a bummer man anything with the
bow
no it's just it's just a rumble but it
but it's just a very basic
rumble like there's nothing it doesn't
feel
unique compared to like yeah that is
just a standard standard rumble
and like i said the triggers don't do
anything all right well this is an xbox
game for me then that's a bummer
yeah so yeah so yeah if if you're
somebody who
happens to own both systems or you're
maybe thinking hey is the ps4 version
have anything more unique to it
um it does not
so maybe maybe xbox is the way to go for
this one um if that's the case
uh versus something like say call of
duty where i would actually recommend
the ps5 version
because of the um with the adaptive
triggers
yeah that that is a game that i really
want to try on ps5
uh unfortunately my squad plays on xbox
but uh it's got cross play though
yeah but then i have to like connect to
the p the pc to
chat with them because discord isn't on
the consoles
that's another thing that i would really
like
both consoles to do that i'm super
disappointed neither of them did
is is um there needs to be a more
uniform
like party system for yeah
cross cross games you know yeah and
honestly i'm tired of them
complaining about losing because of me
playing on pc
so they're like oh we want to turn off
cross play because
all the pc players are beating us and
i'm like
get good man get good get good yeah
fools doesn't mean anything
yeah fools um but we we we're we're good
we play all the time and we beat pc
players all the time but
oh the one time we lose to a pc player
fun fact though
you can plug in mouse and keyboard
on your ps5 and play it that way in fact
uh
oh yeah assassin's creed actually lets
you do this as well
um look at this weird stuff yeah so look
if you go to the control settings
there's straight up mouse and keyboard
which is weird so here uh do you want to
try this actually
sure um i could i could give this a try
this will be
an interesting experience
hold on let me go grab my um yep there
look at that just unlocked
sure yeah uh jean-luc i don't know if
you can hear me i hope you can um
but some people are saying i'm a little
hot on the mic
okay
yeah massacre i think i think console
players
the aim assist helps out a lot
i agree uh it's it's not it's not like
and it's not aimbot but like
it's just enough to get you give you
like a
slight edge um a great pc player will
obviously
beat you no matter what but
okay yep who's using this keyboard that
is
uh yeah look at this that is
wild dude playing with a mouse and
keyboard now
i don't know if i actually want to play
oh my god the sensitivity uh
no just go just go just go just go no i
can't i literally
the sensitivity is insane holy jesus
um
[Music]
mouth sensitivity yeah like all the way
down please
hey go
cool that is really weird you know what
i get it for shooters yeah i was gonna
say i don't wanna i wanna
let's switch back to cod for a sec
because uh
oh you know what here's a weird thing
that this does that
really bothers me for whatever because i
technically have both versions the ps5
and ps4 version sometimes call of duty
likes to default back to the ps4 version
so right now it says like hey you need
to download the game because it says
this is the ps4 version
even though i don't have the ps4 version
installed
uh so i have to switch to the ps5
version
and now i can play i don't know why it
keeps defaulting back especially because
i'm on the ps5 so you think it would
just
default to the version that i have
installed which is the ps5 version
it's really weird uh uh
don't care i'm a little louder than you
jean-luc so maybe turn me down slightly
um i could do that i can do that maybe
drop me down like a decibel or two
yeah hold on i have to unplug
plug my mouse back into my computer
that's so weird that's that it was
really weird to see an assassin's creed
but uh i guess that's pretty cool man
yeah it's it's super cool um yeah
yes ps4 games can be played online on
the ps5
um yes in backwards compatibility mode
oh yeah gamespot thanks for pointing
that out um
jean-luc and i were talking about that
but my my camera will turn
green for some reason um not sure what
that is
that is that is weird
uh so i don't think there's anyone
online but we could just do like a bot
thing
just uh yeah just to show it
um start
start match and then all that's
happening let's go to settings
let's go to
wait you're playing on controller oh
wait no hold on
oh no oh i forgot call of duty you
actually have to manually
uh switch it
assassin's creed will just do it
automatically call of duty
it's because um
so um for matchmaking purposes is why
they do it
so if i go to keyboard
yeah okay now i should be able to do it
uh black ops cold war does run 120 hertz
on ps5
it does it right now
this is the capture device but it does
it does run
team deathmatch
all right aim down sights
does it feel all right yeah it feels
like i'm playing it on mouse
uh keyboard just feels like i'm playing
uh the pc game really
wow that's pretty cool it is cool
uh yeah this is not this
this is not new because it this was on
the old consoles but it's still cool to
see
it it is not new but it's interesting to
see that it's just becoming more of a
universal thing
like yeah especially with the assassin's
creed yeah assassin's creed dude because
call last year is called duty
um but it's not seeing assassin's creed
do it and then it feels like this
the gap between console and um
pc is lessening by the day
it really does especially uh some games
have graphic settings
like bright memory on the xbox has
straight up graphic settings which is
wild wild um cool but hey
why don't we jump out um
let's finish let's finish with sac boy
because people were wanting to see that
sounds good
nice best play thank you there you go
thank you got it
uh back to the controller yep nice
yeah it just goes right back to the
controller when i unplug uh
where where are you sac boy there you
are
yeah this game's cool i i like it a lot
um
like it's not quite a mario game but
it's it's still
still damn damn fun damn charming
gamecube
yeah it's got like you know you get
little costumes like like the other
the little big planet games uh a lot of
fun
little and stuff like that uh
it barely goes above 100 frames per
second that
so for 120 hertz modes it unlocks the
frame rate to go up to 120
but you can use variable refresh rate
monitors you can use whatever you want
to make it look smooth uh what level is
the dmca
level uh go go forward well i i this is
yeah i know go up yeah uh
i think it's that one right to your left
this one hasn't unlocked yet okay so you
play ready yeti go
okay
uh you will you will know before you
start playing also that red riding hood
sack boy costume is really cute all the
costumes are really cute
yeah they're i i unlocked the yak right
away because the yak was
adorable
uh this this soundtrack i think
is made up of like popular songs
remixed into scores i would say
the original little big planet did
something kind of similar
i think it was more indie stuff yeah
because
cause like i i i was listening to it i'm
like
this sounds like michael jackson's don't
stop till you get enough
but i wasn't sure uh
you gotta roll we're gonna roll oh there
we go oh
keep tapping
there we go uh so i've been tested
streaming
um on the ps4 uh or star on the ps5 to
twitch or youtube
but uh from what i've seen um it's
giving you a lot more options to make a
stream
look more professional like an actual
twitch stream
um it's not quite streamlabs um
or obs but they're definitely like the
ps5 camera you can remove the background
um get that two times yeah
oh my god i never saw this
that's dope
punch him
uh this one has a cool um
when you pick up items the trigger
gets a little tense it's a nice feeling
oh i got
got rolled on dude
uh so the ps5 um
does not use freesync or jsync um
i think when they
enable it it's going to be just the hdmi
2.1
variable refresh rate um
yeah i i would have loved it if they
included freesync
need to but just to
have it work with with like
regular modders too but you know that's
that's the way it goes sometimes oh
um let's see
uh i'm not 100 sure if the ps5 has down
sampling for
1080p tvs um
that is a good question um
yeah i don't even want to say it might
just in case
yeah i i generally don't know
uh yeah when i say when if i ever say
something like when they enable it or
when they update the console it's not on
the console yet
oh my god dude that was that yeti wanted
you
oh oh
nice now secret a lot of cool secrets in
this game
uh all right yeah so so jean-luc's gonna
have to pick up these peppers
and throw them into his mouth and when
he like pulls the trigger
it like kind of has a little
little uh resistance to it that feels
nice
yeah yeah
so i i did not get enough peppers into
this guy's mouth
look at him slapping his belly anyone
who slaps their belly when they get food
is a-okay in my votes
nice is it gonna give you the nope
i guess you need all of them man that's
a bummer dang
direction that's hard nah no you can't
unfortunately
that's that's the one bummer is that
like there are a lot of times when i'll
be like oh crap i missed something
but now i've gone down a slope i can't
climb back up or something like that
yeah so you have to like do it on a new
go which is like
fine but it would have been nice to just
you know
if i could go been able to yeah it's
it's
it's it's a little disappointing angry
oh nice
oh no oh
my god dude okay you got the you got the
checkpoint
there is over there oh there is yeah
yeah
just wait scaring me
don't roll in
uh i don't remember sack boy having a
voice i don't care for that
it's a little weird it's a little weird
because he like he doesn't talk but
he'll like
make like grunts and he sounds like a
like an eight-year-old
and i don't like that it's weird um i
don't care for it
there are definitely some things that uh
make me go oh this was made for with
like obviously a kid-friendly game
sure but like there's a talking
character
there are a lot of talking characters
and like i almost feel like it would be
better
like they're good they're well voiced
they're they're charming they're cute
it's fine
but i almost feel like they should have
um like just like
they make noises i i completely agree
um and then also something like sac boy
sounding like a little kid makes me
think oh
they want kids to go i'm sac boy
or something like that yeah
run crash bandicoot
i'll see you can tap to roll
uh which button uh circle okay
oh looks like you didn't even need it
but yeah you can you can like that's
kind of how you run in this game is you
just keep tapping
oh oh oh no prick this time that
oh well i get another chance
i'll trade sack boy for glover any day
ben says
then wood
oh get out of here get out of here uh
people that have a new playstation and a
new psn id um
will be able to access the plus
collection as long as they are
as long as they're subscribed to ps plus
yes that is a feature if you have a ps5
and ps plus you get the plus collection
a little disappointing that would have
been cool if they brought that to ps4
the plus collection yeah like why not
like it's the end of the console's life
like
um yeah i mean like like you raised the
price
yeah like a couple times technically the
games you get on that collection
you can then download them on your ps4
but
like at that point oh but but you own
the ps5 at that point
so oh right yeah
that is very true so it's like you can
only get it if you own a ps5 at that
point it's like i guess i could download
these on my ps4 too but like why
would i
yeah that's a good point that's a bum i
was really excited there for a second
i was like oh that's cool i'm gonna play
jay's gone on my ps4 pro now
oh hell yeah dude uh
yeah so you get days gone with the plus
collection which has a ps5 update
so it runs really nice yeah uh
yup ghost is probably the most
impressive of the um
the suggestion days gone are the most
impressive because cause
days gone didn't have any graphic
settings uh
graphic options so it's just now getting
like dynamic 4k60 which is great
ghost is interesting because it had
performance
um and it had frame rate mode or uh
resolution mode now the resolution mode
runs at 60
on the ps5 which makes frame rate mode
like pointless like you shouldn't use
frame rate mode
when playing on the ps5 there's no
reason to use it anymore
it's really cool it's super cool really
cool and i and i would
really hope to see more games do that
for example god award doesn't do that so
god of war you still have to pick
um you know it also has a
graphics or performance mode but if you
pick the resolution mode
um it's still locked at 30 versus like
the performance mode
you can get up to 60 now but it's still
like 1080
um so it'll be blurrier so that's kind
of disappointing i was hoping it would
get a
a mode similar to uh um
are we doing this are we doing this uh
yeah sure
should do should we i don't know it's
it's a cool level
why not just just start it just start it
and then
my phone starts blowing up shut it down
uh we'll don't go too far
just go a little bit into it
welcome to the jungle oh we got fun
games
so all right you're going for it
oh okay here we go okay yeah yeah yeah i
see now
so uh just keep talking just keep
talking uh
just talk over the dmca what music
there's no music here dmc isn't here mr
mr dm
and mr ca please don't do anything to
our stream
okay but it's also like
it's cool like the music stops and
then every starts to the to the beat
yeah it's really cool this is really
cool
reminds me of uh reminds me of spray man
legends
all right maybe maybe we should yeah
let's hop out of there just in case
30 second rule uh yeah
that's awesome uh okay well
we're kind of coming up on the end of
the stream here is there any last things
people wanted to quickly
see or or know about before we uh we
shut this down
yeah um hey go go to the game library
see what
show them what you got if there's
something we can show them quickly oh
sure
um show them bugs thanks
just show them quickly bug snacks i
haven't even started at bug snacks
oh then don't show them bug sex uh
because that's going to take a while to
get into anything okay yeah
uh yeah i don't know man i i i'm
really into the ps5 um i
i like i've always loved playstation
consoles i was not a ps4
guy um oh yeah show them ghosts yeah
i'll show them ghosts just so
you can appreciate the that hot yeah
uh yeah it's it's pretty
it's pretty damn good man i i like this
game a lot and
i want to play through it on the ps5
yeah i never finished it uh but now i
want to
i want to go back and like replay it uh
we have experienced the tempest 3d audio
um it is a noticeable difference um
but does not feel essential yet um
but it's it's there's no harm in using
it because it's it's
free included and it works with every
head pair of headphones
oh yeah we should show them the ps store
before we end it too oh sure
uh you did see resident evil 4 it's it's
the ps4 version
oh yeah so yeah so right here i am
what what mode am i on right now let's
see
higher resolution mode so i am on
high resolution mode and it is
buttery smooth yeah it is really nice
uh yeah this is a good this is a good
game man and uh
i it's cool that this game feels like a
ps5
game yes it's getting the hardware that
it deserved in the first place
uh a lot of games are and hopefully more
games get like
optimizations and stuff like that
because
god damn it is a good looking game
um yeah so that's the ps5 guys
thanks for joining us um maybe you can
hop out and show them the store real
quick
sure sure um gosh it is
it is a cool console man i'm not i
wasn't a ps4 guy i played it
uh i i preferred my pc and xbox
but uh yeah yeah
it's uh it's it's good man
it's a good console i'm excited to play
games on it the controller is
unbeatable man it's really really
special controller is really the thing
that makes it feel
like next-gen to me when it when it's
fully utilized
um so yeah here's the store it's you
just load right into it like
it's which is cool like there's no
waiting for the store to load anymore
um you know you can immediately just
like
yep here's horizon and then i could add
it to my wish list
uh look at all this stuff
yeah um i can
buy some uh buy some kudos for fall guys
hell yeah
download ps4 games bunch of free to play
games that are coming over from the ps4
um some that are getting updates uh
it is it is good man it's a good console
and i'm excited to see the future of it
same for the xbox man i i honestly feel
like there has never been a better time
to be a gamer on either platform
it's it's really it's really good i
agree
um but hey thanks a bunch for joining me
showing off the ps5 sean luke
uh thanks to everyone in the chat for
watching and your wonderful questions
uh we absolutely adore you we're so
thankful that you came
and uh un until next time uh i hope you
guys get your ps5 sooner rather than
later
and uh we will talk to you soon
bye everyone bye